you know how I know that Henry really
likes the movie you flew in from Japan
out there by the way have you seen the
movie sure where did you see it huh
when did you say okay good yes nobody's
funny cuz he could it something comes up
on you and you're not quite sure who
said it in hasn't seen it because it's
its most movies by this stage I've seen
at this stage of the game I'll sit at
fifteen twenty thirty times and I've
only seen this move three times I said
it was that actually felt that's
something I wanted to bring up I'm
obsessed with the editing process
because ultimately that's the final
rewrite so I'm curious with with your
films in general do they change a lot in
the editing room and let's start with
that yeah I think it depends I mean you
know I overwrite these things and you
know I spent years on the dialog one way
or the other washing it through washing
after washing it through then you turn
up on the day and you yell let's try
something else
so sometimes it works sometimes the
rhythm works sometimes it doesn't
sometimes an actor's got a better idea
but you try you as long as you've got a
plan you can stick to the plan until you
don't but it's quite good to have a plan
but yeah if someone can trump one of my
ideas then I'm I'm gonna take the credit
so cuz we've been talked about a lot
today you do rewrite heavy on the day
yeah you're like your mind is hottest
and the synapses are clicking in the
moment not five minutes before yeah no
I'm sorry about live yeah I do
i I do feel quite guilty about this you
don't feel that guilty about it Wow
could you say you've been mauled over
two years workers streaming through the
dialogue right yeah how many times what
percentage of your last idea
is your best idea in retrospect um well
I think probably what it is is refining
of an idea so it's it's rare that I
change 100% and what's on the page but
it's probably 20% and I would say that's
just sharpening the pencil and but
you're right in the sense that you know
the creative synapse is are firing in
the moment much more so than they can
really at any other time but I find this
is particularly dialogue heavy this film
and there's a particular cadence and
rhythm to the dialogue so in that sense
you had it I can when I'm listening to
you is you would have found out is if
you're delivering lines ago it just
isn't a rhythm just isn't quite right
and that does force some introspection
and some changes in the moment but I
reckon you know the film are doing now
is almost 90% of the stuff is on the
data route it's well it's just I have
the sort of the beginning into this I
have the beginning of the scene I have
the end of the scene of the pub
surrender to it there and then I find
out we're very efficient but this is so
dialog dependent this one there I reckon
is 20% the sharpening the pencil when
the actors are there and you're in the
moment and it plus it's also more fun
you know these things need to be fun and
there needs to be I think some form of a
creative activity on the day otherwise
you sit you sit there's a dialog Bosch
and it does feel like there needs to be
some participation from all creative
personalities well I mean you bring up
an excellent point because a lot of
movie sets you're dealing with just the
script and with Guy it's changing all
the time I know that happened with you
with on the Sherlock Holmes movies with
Robert what is it like for the three of
you in when you're basically being given
it's gonna go this way no it's gonna go
this way
right on the day come on I mean first my
first reaction was very frustrated put
that I worked on this I
I hear this meter this works but then
what I found is most of the time guys
idea in the moment for line change
there's actually better and so when I
click on that guy get dad I get it I get
that clicks better ok I'm going to get
in here and and and and keep tugging the
balls and make them try make that work
if it wasn't better or didn't feel like
it was better and more true I've been
frustrated longer but it that got to be
I go I was it was obvious very early on
you come in with a lot of agility you
should come in with a lot of agility
when you're gonna work with guy because
he's gonna have a lot of ideas in the
moment and most time we're gonna be
better here here
maybe it's funny as I say I will if
someone else could trumpet idea they're
not I don't care where it comes from and
it probably happened once for horrible
way but no if it does and it does then
it does keep the process alive and
exciting otherwise you are going to work
sorry once you like math you saying is
that once you give in to it and come on
set with this you know not to expect too
much or you know to prepare too much you
sort of just go with it and I think we
do as act as we sort of live off that
adrenalin and you know that's a feeling
of sponsor
spontaneity is actually quite liberating
there's nothing like having a bubble
burst that onset just before you around
her yeah you know a very very big big
dreams of dialogue and the costumes not
right he's not wearing what we should be
wearing we got to change up the the
pacing and stuff like that and so for
for me on my first day I don't know I
remember I do remember you in your first
day it was the biggest scene that I had
with with with Matthew and and there was
a lot of sort of just getting getting my
outfit right to set the tone for the
rest of it and and I do remember sort of
just like thinking
[ __ ] what I got myself in for like this
is an absolute like you either sink or
swim it literally as you you're thrown
to the sort of sharks as such and and
and the collaborative spirit is there
it's just you know it's really up to you
if you partake and and and sort of have
a say in it or you sit back as an as an
observer and and often it's it's much
more fun when you when you have your
little word in it I also just figured if
it didn't do it a lot of my performance
might end up on the cutting room floor
where you can see that someone has a
particular idea and I tried sort of
wrestle them away from that idea they
think it just keeps coming back in again
at a certain point garage I think there
were a couple of suggestions at the
stadium when we were filming and maybe
not that and that was the end of it one
of the things about this film is
everyone and it looks like they've
stepped off like a shoot from GQ there's
just some great costumes I know you
really are on with fashion talk a little
bit about basically the fashion in the
movie and why what is your thing with
with costumes well sure if it's fashion
you're a fashionista are there well I
think what you want is something more
classical and hopefully something and we
did we made up our mind that we were
going down a particular route there was
more classical and less susceptible to
trends and I can get quite excited about
this particular subject because we yes
yeah you and I have had this
conversation a few times but yeah I
think it's in fact there was a it was I
don't think it made the movie sadly but
there was an enormous philosophical
explanation of who wears the clothes of
the clothes where demands and the man
with clothes and I would have actually
liked to have gone it's a wonderful
metaphor for life right who's wearing
what so in part
the film is about are you wearing the
suit was the suit wearing you literally
and metaphorically so you can get pretty
philosophical about clothing in general
I just I don't see clothing is just
clothing
I see clothing as a philosophy well you
said it didn't make the movie I think it
was do one scene that could work for an
entire movie coming up yeah no but it
certainly I think it once you once you
bite that off you've really got a follow
you've got to be consistent and
tenacious with that premise it's in a
way it's almost not worth tickling it
you've really got to grab it if you
gather if you've got time he's got an
hour monologue to give you on on gravity
and formation and style I'm already
giving the wrap-up signal so I'm going
to stop and say I cannot open that door
but believe me when I say I would have
loved to have heard it and I'm looking
forward to trying your whiskey Long
Branch Bergeron I'm sorry
I've only plugged it 72 times I
apologize bourbon my bad
thank you so much for your time and
congrats on the movie it's so much fun